la central nuclear más grande de Europa
nuevamente bajo ataque la planta de
saporiya actualmente bajo control ruso
ha tenido dos jornadas de bombardeos
entre el sábado y el domingo como en
ocasiones anteriores Ucrania y Rusia se
culpan mutuamente de los hechos mientras
los organismos internacionales hacen un
llamado de atención el
régimen de kiev naces en sus
provocaciones con el objetivo de crear
una amenaza de desastre Industrial en la
central nuclear de zaporilla el 19 de
noviembre la artillería ucraniana lanzó
11 proyectiles contra la estación en la
mañana del 20 de noviembre la estación
fue bombardeada dos veces por militares
ucranianos 915 y las 9:45 de la mañana
se lanzaron 12 proyectiles aunque los
bombardeos no son críticos para la
seguridad varios edificios y
equipamientos sufrieron daños el
operador Estatal ucraniano aseguró que
los daños se causaron en los pasos a
desnivel de comunicación de los cuerpos
especiales los tanques de almacenamiento
de agua química un sistema de purga de
generador de y sistemas auxiliares se
produjeron explosiones en el sitio de
esta importante planta de energía
nuclear lo cual es completamente
inaceptable quien quiera que esté detrás
de esto debe detenerse de inmediato como
he dicho varias veces se está jugando
con fuego grossy reiteró su llamada
Moscú y kef para acordar cuanto antes
una zona de seguridad nuclear alrededor
de la central a finales de septiembre el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin
celebró la anexión de cuatro regiones
ucranianas entre esas apurilla donde se
encuentra la planta